and we start with a Fox News Alert this
Friday night welcome to Hannity tonight
while Democrats devote almost all of
their time and energy to the riot at the
Capitol on January the 6th uh 18 months
ago well America's economy is literally
coming apart at the seams and frankly so
is the president take a look
well in climate change we've actually
made some real moves I mean we have we
have you know one in seven of all the
changes that have taken place in terms
of solar wind and and and and wind pumps
and I mean pumps and like uh have
occurred in the last 18 months we've
moved that was Joe Biden's first
sit-down interview in 118 days and
despite a flurry of well nothing but
softball questions from a democratic
activist pretending to be a late night
comedian Biden still struggled to
communicate he could barely get words
out he had no answers for the economic
problems we are facing and it got a lot
worse today now inflation went up yet
again to an all-new 41-year High 8.6
percent now the cost of food is up 10.1
percent the cost of housing seven
percent rent is up in some places as
high as 20 percent household energy
bills they're up a whopping 19.1 percent
and meanwhile the average cost for a
gallon of gas has now more than doubled
since Biden took over as president now
over five dollars a gallon Nationwide
for the first time ever remember when he
first became president on day one you
were only paying 2.39 for a gallon of
gasoline now the price of the pump is so
high that deputies from one Michigan
County they're now reportedly dealing
with non-urgent calls remotely over the
phone because they can't afford to fuel
a patrol car now to make matters even
worse we have major supply shortages
that continues to play the country hot
sauce by the way so that's the latest
product that might soon go missing from
store shelves and in order to cope with
the shortages and inflation and high gas
prices will now manufacturers look at
this and I don't really blame them they
have to shrink the size of their
packages in other words not only do you
pay more but you're getting less for
what you pay for the AP is now calling
it shrinkflation and don't worry because
Joe Biden knows just who to blame
international shipping companies let's
blame them or Putin or Trump or Fox News
or Sean Hannity take a look I have to
admit to you
a lot of us have elected official been
in office for a while
every once in a while something you
learn makes you viscerally angry
like if you had the person in front of
you you'd want to pop them
I really mean it
there are nine nine major ocean line
shipping companies
that ship from Asia to the United States
nine they form three Consortium
these companies have raised their prices
by as much as one thousand percent
wait a minute the guy that gets blown
over multiple times climbing up the
steps to Air Force One always wants to
punch somebody it gets blown over by the
wind anyway Joe went on to blame Florida
Senator Rick Scott Congressional
Republicans he blamed Exxon Mobil he
previously was blaming Vladimir Putin
big meat conglomerates covid-19 greedy
corporations people with diabetes
climate change billionaires and when all
else fails just blame Donald Trump
naturally Biden himself has not accepted
any of the share of responsibility or
blamed forget the trillions of dollars
in new spending the artificial reduction
of the world's oil and gas supply
because of his well adherence to climate
alarmism and that religious cult and
according to Joe that has nothing to do
with gas prices or inflation it has
everything to do with it now meanwhile
Biden's old friend from the Senate
Claire mccaskill well she has her own
well to be honest Baddie and saying
conspiracy theory about gas prices and
inflation that involves Mitch McConnell
in January 6. he can't make this up
either take a look I am a hundred
percent sure Mitch McConnell was tuned
in
what's he thinking tonight he's no
friend of Donald Trump's no he can't
stand Donald Trump hates him he's
worried about Donald Trump's candidates
winning Republican primaries which makes
it harder for him to take back power but
you know what he's thinking tonight well
I sure hope gas prices stay really high
that's what he's thinking because he
really wants to distract the American
public from the reality of what we saw
tonight I think he's hoping that the
high gas prices and the inflationary
pressures in our economy will be enough
to make people forget and just want to
change out the deficits well it's
politics
isn't this great to see Claire mccaskill
she's a perfect fit for NBC News because
that's all they peddle our conspiracy
theories now reality the GOP is the only
party willing to take the logical steps
that would lower prices at the pump
which would help ease inflationary
pressure by increasing domestic
production of oil and gas building the
Keystone XL pipeline to increase the oil
and gas supply from Canada according to
the Alberta Premier if we had finished
it we would be getting every single day
900 000 barrels of Canadian Oil every
day and that would lower the price of a
gallon of gasoline and by the way Joe
also needs to end the restrictions that
he has put on the energy sector of our
economy now these are concrete steps
that Biden could take right now but it's
not going to happen he is refusing to
change course at all he is beholden to
the radical new green deal socialists so
now from the guy that brought you
America's winner of severe illness and
death buckle up for Biden's summer of
stagflation and suffering now I'll be
honest I don't want to bring you bad
news every night but that's all there is
with the economy because the president
is in way over his head or whoever is
really in charge now at this point his
presidency is an abject failure worse
than even Jimmy Carter I didn't think
I'd see that in my lifetime our country
would absolutely be better off if he
retired early honestly I don't know
what's keeping him in the white house he
has plenty of money he loves his beach
house in Delaware we know he loves that
he spends most of his time there so for
God's sake Joe to use your words for the
good of the country maybe let the adult
adults
take charge once again let somebody more
confident run the country let somebody
that's not struggling cognitively let
someone maybe who understands uh the
free market capitalism businesses this
supply chain someone who has the courage
to actually stand up to the Socialist
occult climate alarmist cult in your
party that you're a part of now sadly I
don't think there's a Democrat left in
Washington with maybe the exception of
Joe manchin who would fit that
description hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else